die radikale
transformationspolitik ich würde auch
sagen Abbau und rückbaupolitik in
unserem Land die da gerade maßgeblich
von grünen aber eben auch den anderen
Parteien geduldet vonstatten geht
erschreckt mich immer mehr und ich frage
mich in anderen Ländern und ich bekomme
aus der Nähe von Frankreich aus
Baden-Württemberg wir hatten Frankreich
vor der Haustür in so einem Land wie
Frankreich werden die Bürger glaube ich
schon längst auf der Straße wenn wenn es
solche radikalen Pläne die
offensichtlich zu Lasten auch der
einfachen Leute und unseres
Wirtschaftsstandorts gehen umgesetzt
werden sollen und ich frage mich die
Deutschen sind
sehr geduldig aber irgendwann muss die
Stimmung denke ich auch mal kippen und
ich glaube da bin ich bei ihnen schon
Herr Stahl diese Inschrift auf dem
Reichstag dem deutschen Volker an diese
Inschrift muss man einige diese Leute
tatsächlich lautstarker erinnern glaube
ich